wait can i feel everyone's arms oh my
god
wait
okay
one of the hardest parts of dating is
guessing someone's intentions
are they truly interested in you or are
they just looking out for themselves how
do you know when you're being played
we created a game show to find out one
bachelorette is looking for love and
will meet five potential matches and i'm
in it for love i'm in it for love i'm in
it for love i'm in it for love i'm in it
for love here's the catch some of them
are lying and trying to win a cash prize
can our bachelorette eliminate the gold
diggers and find a true match or will
they just get played this is love or
money
welcome to love or money are you guys
excited yeah thrilled hannah these are
your potential matches do you see your
future boyfriend in here
possibly
hi i'm hannah i am vegan eco-friendly i
am pretty creative and i'm a youtuber
and what do you look for in a match
someone that's silly someone that's fun
and someone who will drink and dance
with me
will you guys drink and dance with her
easily yes
now that you met your bachelorette
you're gonna decide if you're in it for
love or money underneath your chair you
have an envelope and a marker and you're
gonna write if you're in it for love or
money and just so you know once you put
love or money you are locked in for the
whole show and you cannot change your
answer
oh my gosh
this is round one and it's all about the
first impression hannah you have 10
minutes to free for all ask any
questions you want and speed date all
these lovely guys and the timer starts
now alrighty first can we go down the
line and say
name age and what do you do for a job
all right my name is logan 26 and i am
working at chipotle while i pursue
acting hey i'm darren i like your socks
i'm 23 and i work at a tech company my
name is emmanuel i'm 22. i also like
your socks and i work as a physicist at
stanford remotely hi i'm sebastian i'm
21 and i'm looking for a marketing
internship right now and i also like
your socks
oh my god i'm pearson i'm 23.
i'm a filmmaker um your socks are all
right
okay all righty
you seem like you're a lot of fun and
the dancing thing really oh my god it
really got my heart beating so i'm about
that
favorite drink
go oh thin lemon i'm a baby i like
lemonade cute i've been drinking a lot
of scotch lately because i'm an old man
i guess
maybe like a ham's beer tequila sunrise
jack and coke okay i just i want to like
see height differences okay wait i just
want to like come up to you guys
oh this is
okay
again okay
what are you guys giggling about
this is so normal
i'm by far the shortest on here
okay okay um wait can i feel everyone's
arms
can i do that
as you wish
you please man
oh my god
wait
okay
oh my god you guys
stop it
um this is really fun
oh my god no
okay give me the tea
i like all their personalities so far
yeah they seem great they made me feel
really comfortable i hope i made them
feel comfortable even though it was kind
of weird i'm like oh no i shouldn't have
asked to touch their arms
i went down and they were like really
relaxed and then i went to touch and
they went
oh no that was great i loved it do you
think they're all here for love some for
money can you tell yet i can't tell
i know i know i'm nervous okay so i know
you said you liked all of them but you
have to eliminate too soon
do you know who you're gonna pick
welcome back guys did you guys have fun
meeting hannah a lot of a lot well two
of you are about to be eliminated
hannah
logan i'm so sorry yeah that's fun um
and you
oh
okay
bye guys sorry our fallen brothers
this is round two hannah's going to get
a little deeper with her potential
matches and she has five minutes to
speed date all of them hannah are you
ready yes
nice to meet you nice to meet you
sebastian again hello hi
are we started are we starting wow now
i'm already
a blank i can't think um
you sound like so much fun i like to
think that i am i like your style a lot
and your arms are nice thank you
i do a lot of things with them you do a
lot of things with with your arms yeah
so you surf i do yes not well but i try
no way no i know it's the hair i wish i
was like a superstar but okay but what
what are you the best at
what are you doing any second dates but
i guess you'd have to find out after
yeah oh
if we we go out and party and a bar
fighter rises i could protect you for
sure yeah
there was an apocalypse like do you
think you would be the last one standing
i make it to the final rounds i think
wait what scares you what scares me yeah
probably
living in a world without family like
being the only one left
oh my god what about yourself um
something so weird about me is um i was
always afraid of people in like mascot
costumes
like chuck e cheese like stuff like that
okay or i like sports games
yes
yeah what kind of what kind of youtube
videos you make okay so a couple years
ago this thing happened where my hair
fell out and i posted a video just
talking about how my hair fell out and
then it kind of blew up and people
wanted to know what i was doing next so
now it just kind of turned into me
just testing beauty things and making
people feel more comfortable with
themselves that's inspiring
[Music]
oh my goodness we'd love to stay in chat
but uh yeah we'll maybe see you later
i'll see ya you want to hug yeah
i'll catch you later i'll see you later
he smells good
okay hannah so how do you feel i feel
good
the hug between you and emmanuel
it was like long it felt so real
good hugger but then the hug between you
and sebastian you said he smells good he
smelled good yeah darren i wish we got a
chance to hug like i wish i could i know
that i felt like there was a pause and
then you both were like we were like
are you ready to eliminate one
guy yes are you nervous yeah oh i feel
bad
unfortunately we've come to the time
where hannah has to eliminate one person
and just a reminder hannah
one of these guys or all of them two of
them could be in it for the money oh my
god so pick wisely okay follow your
heart
you got this okay
i'm um
manual
bye
it was a nice hug too you're a good
hugger thank you
i'm not tall enough for sure but i think
i think your arms made up for it yeah i
do a lot of physical activity i don't
know
congratulations guys you're moving on to
the last round
we can do one two
she feels left out no i get it i got it
i got it i get it yeah thank you
round three is all about getting more
intimate with hannah's potential matches
are you ready to get closer with them
yes i am dig into their personal lives
take a seat i call this the love couch
oh boy i'm excited now
let's lounge together
hello hi how are you hello i'm good we
meet again we do meet again wow um
i don't know what's some i don't know
what some deep things
so if young you saw you right now like
what would you think
cut your hair
no way really i don't know maybe you
give off really good energy okay i'm
glad you as well you do as well thank
you
[Music]
nice have you found happiness in past
relationships
i would say i have i've only had one
serious relationship and that was maybe
three years ago and we ended on a good
note it's just the timing didn't really
line up mine was also three years ago
we've been out of the game for a while
yeah we have to out of the game and then
covet didn't really make it much easier
no no no no have you like tried to date
around in the past year this is my first
time meeting a stranger even in like 14
months oh my god i'm glad lucky you very
very what what'd you say you learned
from your past relationships
trust is the most important thing is the
foundation of everything i think it's
easy to kind of tell white lies here and
there you know be like oh i'm tired like
instead of being like i'm tired i don't
want to see you be like oh like i'm busy
and i think right i think hearing that
as well as also saying that i think is
pretty damaging about yourself i felt
like i was gaslit a lot uh like they try
to make me feel crazy for like saying
certain things or doing certain things i
guess
so um that's terrible yeah would you
benefit a lot from being in like a
serious relationship right now
do you feel that
i think well when i'm dating i kind of
date for happiness i'm not really the
type to date for like marriage or
anything but like if your happiness
turns into marriage eventually then
that's the good direction but right
i don't know
again
wow
thanks for like lounging with me of
course
oh yeah well uh maybe we'll see you
maybe i'll see you i'm sure i'll see you
bye we'll see ya we'll see
i feel like that went really well i
think it did too those were some like
great conversations they flowed okay
sebastian i mean i feel like
like he's into me as much as i'm into
him
really getting to know each other i feel
like he's sad every time time is up yes
darren
body language was so relaxed like
comfortable with himself okay and i like
that okay but i don't know i don't know
why i have a little bit of a feeling
that he's in it for money
and not for the not for love do you have
that feeling with sebastian
no not at all he thinks his heart's on
his sleeve he's in it for love yes he
wants you yes
hey guys
hello hi all right hannah the time has
come for you to choose who you want to
go on another date with just a reminder
they could be in it for the money but
they also could be in it for the love so
take your time
lead with your heart who are you
choosing
um
i just like like lounging on the couch
with both of you seeing how you lounge
was nice
well
i choose
sebastian
would you go on a date with me i would
love to
okay
can we hug
were you shocked when things took a
downward spiral downward spiral i felt
like it was more of a of a cliff not a
spiral
okay guys this is the final round the
show is all about seeing past the
surfaces and trying to get to someone's
true intentions do you think you did
that today hannah yes do you think you
made the right choice i think so
really okay okay this is lover money and
here you go time to reveal what you
chose
oh no
what
i didn't see that coming i didn't feel
like going i'm the bad guy but i mean
good for you congratulations well i
can't have you here any longer you can't
get her number you can't get her socials
you have to leave without even saying
bye really yeah all right
it's been fun
hannah
wow
what wow
what
like
i'm
speechless same
[Music]
i feel evil did you enjoy the
conversations with hannah she's great
yeah i mean i feel bad for my choice
even if it wasn't for money would you
have taken hannah on a date i would have
loved to yeah she's fun she's cute i
mean
i'm traveling like all next year so it
just didn't really make sense for me to
like get into a committed relationship
right now and now you can pay for your
travels exactly exactly how do you feel
i feel
beyond shook me too yeah that was crazy
i really thought he was in it for the
long haul me too like i couldn't wait to
text you and be like yeah i was like
ready to go to malibu with them right
he's ready to learn how to surf i know
i'm sad but you know maybe there's
someone for me out there definitely
[Music]
you